Peggy 18  [Music]  my name's Poorna and i'm gonna tell you  about the worst bloody holiday ever  i woke up one morning to discover that  the goddamn zombie apocalypse had  arrived i was immune to whatever this  plague was i met a few others who were  immune and somehow we were all elected  to save everybody else each one of us  had contact with these things  your blood could be used to make some  sort of antidote well what do we do we  do the right thing  let's do this  they coming we're gonna survive we need  to get the hell out of here  loyal desire to take you into custody  and transport you to a secure quarantine  area  the rumor is they're trying to weaponize  this plate for use as a bioweapon  we don't have much time it's about to be  mute we're a team right we stick  together  [Music]